[Music]
what is this you guys I'm excited for
the diamonds and the chocolates as I am
every year these are the Oscars gift
bags this year two hundred and fifteen
thousand dollars worth of stuff I love
penguins okay I will deal with you later
it is that time of year again we've been
watching a bunch of award shows and it's
all been leading up to the Academy
Awards
so it's also the time for the annual
everyone wins nominee gift bags so
here's how these gift bags work all the
goodies in this bag is given to the
nominees in the top categories like Best
Actor Best Actress Best Supporting Actor
Best Supporting Actress and Best
Director by a company called distinctive
assets I'd like to note that that
company is not affiliated with the
Academy the Academy is not giving these
gift bags so there's that and they have
the option to claim everything that's in
this bag claim nothing in the bag or
just take a few things like maybe with
this penguin in the past some stars have
decided to donate these bags to charity
which is really nice so yeah let's see
what they're getting this year and be a
little nosy with what the stars are
gonna claim let the show begin some of
the actors and directors nominated this
year include leonardo dicaprio cynthia
areevo saoirse ronan brad pitt martin
scorsese quentin tarantino literally
hollywood royalty and whether they win
or lose an Oscar they still are gifted
this bag sadly we don't get to keep them
but I can pretend for a day geez where
do I start
oh I love penguins so much so I feel
like this is the cutest thing for a star
to receive with the little thing would
be
and this is by scenic eclipse it's a
yacht company whoo okay well I think
it's soap I think it's soap
oh okay this is a car freshener so it's
a fragrance for your car so maybe they
can use this in their luxury limo rides
or something
what is this you guys I'm excited for
the diamonds and the chocolates as I am
every year ooh it's a necklace that's
actually really pretty this is a 18
karat gold necklace that is assembled by
veterans with disabilities and I think
it's a gorgeous necklace powerful
anti-aging concentrate you know what I
love how they always try to include
beauty products in these bags it says
it'll leave you flawless let's see how
it smells I'm just gonna test it
everything on my hand uh smells like
nothing it's unscented so stars if you
want something unscented to give you
that anti-aging glow cool some beauty
products we have a multi acid
resurfacing treatment pads visibly
improves pores fine lines spots uneven
skin tone and texture okay so I feel
like people will definitely claim these
pads and just have it on their face give
you that red carpet plump oh I'm gonna
go to this bag because it's inviting so
this is a bag that's distributed by
electric array and they work with
indigenous and impoverished artists to
give them sustainable opportunities to
earn living wages which is pretty cool
this is a nice hat would you look at
that whoo nice you get a little fan too
okay so you have a towel for the beach
this is all your beach goodies that you
can use and on one of your luxury
vacations that we'll get to later if you
choose to do that this is a wallet to
put your billions of dollars in well
it's great wish I had some money ooh
more jewelry by Cristina ramela these
are beautiful you can tell everything is
so detailed made by hand like there's a
lot of craftsmanship that went into this
I think I would claim this pita and a
company called DIF made these Sonny's
apparently and they kind of look really
cool this looks like a gold brick let's
see okay okay well it's kind of a gold
brick it is a vegan bath bomb but I'm
there's some gold in here you guys there
is some gold in here can you imagine the
size of the bath tub you have to have to
put this whole bath bomb in I mean I
don't have that but I'm pretty sure
someone it does it is a Royal Crown
Chakra bath bomb with 24 karat gold I'm
pretty sure you can you can slice this
up but if I was a star and I had a giant
bath I would use this giant gold brick
this is over a pound and then we have
throw throw burrito
a dodgeball card game from the creators
of exploding kittens and I think we have
exploding kit in somewhere great so you
have a burrito card game and you have a
kitten card game I don't even see the
cute little burritos I'm gonna take this
one out of the box
[Music]
you throw these is what the box says
hollow tips
I think there are babes
[Applause]
okay shop 24 karat gold all right let's
put this back before it starts
okay tequila some more spirits okay so
this was in last year's bag I remember
because it had one of my favorite things
in there so this is a fancy dental tooth
kit and the best thing in this box is
the breath spray this is the most usable
thing ever it's so small you don't have
to chew gum it's just the best thing oh
this must be a really gosh this is
intense package here come on oh there
you go vodka
gosh before you're thinking of like an
alcohol free drinks not for me and
giving them back but for the stars
decorative home pillow yeah
this is ooh this is really soft and it's
cute it's like a nice kind of subtle
color so yeah the stars get pillows - mm
this is soft Wow oh this is nice and
cozy this is an alpaca throw that's
handmade by artisans in Peru it is very
very soft cute simple design I would
clean this a hundred percent all right I
think we have some Old Spice yeah
this is a very fancy looking bracelet
with gold and silver from Italy I
actually really think this design is
super cool and very like unisex and I
feel like it's something that I would
wear and something like 5 day meal
program fasting mimicking diet okay
there's some bars and some protein
powder some kale crackers in here
there's no chocolate because here we
have ham crackers yeah they're actually
pretty good plant-based healthy healthy
options they got better as you keep
doing blonde hair this definitely looks
like the necklace from Titanic that rose
drops into the water but it's also very
very beautiful
although nominees get a ton of items in
the bag some of the pricier gifts
include vacation vouchers like the
scenic luxury cruise that's valued over
78,000 dollars so there you have it the
2020 Oscars gift bags I really wonder
what everyone will claim I looking this
but lots of cool stuff lots of drinks
lots of beauty products lots of vacation
so good luck to the nominees it's a
party time to return all these stuff
because I can't